I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who are there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello! Hi there!
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，我们是好朋友。现在我们正在做专属于你的终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当时在场的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室名媛。大家好！嗨！
Today we're talking about Tallahassee, not the city, but the off, ladies. Hello. Hi there. Today we're talking about Tallahassee, not the city, but the episode. The episode and maybe we'll also talk about the city. Maybe we will. You have a look on your face like you're planning to talk about the city. Hi.
今天我们要聊的是塔拉哈西，不是这座城市，而是，办公室名媛们。大家好。嗨。今天我们要聊的是塔拉哈西，不是这座城市，而是这一集。这一集，也许我们也会聊聊这座城市。也许会的。你脸上的表情看起来像是在计划聊聊这座城市。嗨。
Hi, what's up, Tallahassee. OK. Well, this was season 8, episode 15, written by Danny Chun and directed by Matt Sone. Here is your summary. The Dunder Mifflin Scranton Special Projects team has arrived in Florida and are introduced to Nelly Bertram, president of Special Projects.
嗨，最近怎么样，塔拉哈西。好的。嗯，这是第八季第十五集，由丹尼·陈编剧，马特·索恩执导。以下是剧情梗概。邓德米夫林斯克兰特别项目团队已经抵达佛罗里达，并被介绍认识了特别项目总裁内莉·伯特姆。
Dunder Mifflin Scranton Special Projects team. That's not easy to say. It's not. Put it on a hat. It's going to barely fit. I know. Dwight is determined to take over as leader of the special projects group or at least vice president and not even
邓德米夫林斯克兰特别项目团队。这可真不好念。确实不好念。印在帽子上吧。几乎戴不下。我知道。德怀特下定决心要接管特别项目小组的领导权，或者至少要当副总裁，甚至连
appendicitis is going to stop him. In a cringey upsetting way for me, as we know that I don't like it when people do not attend to their injuries. And you also don't like it when people get re-injured and like an open wound. No, I do not. Yeah.
阑尾炎也阻止不了他。这对我来说是一种尴尬且令人不安的方式，因为我们都知道，我不喜欢人们不处理自己的伤口。你也不喜欢人们再次受伤，比如有开放性伤口。不，我确实不喜欢。对，我不喜欢。
So this was difficult for me. Not that I enjoy it, but I just know it's something that really, you know, makes you go, ugh. Yeah, it's a soft spot for me. But also in this episode, Jim is gonna take a page from Stanley's book, and he's going to try to teach himself how to lean into fun mode.
所以这对我有难度。倒不是我喜欢看这个，只是我知道这绝对是那种会让你忍不住“呃”出声的东西。对，这是我的死穴。不过在这集里，吉姆也将效仿斯坦利的做法，他要试着让自己进入休闲模式。
He's really seeing Stanley as a bit of a mentor here in Tallahassee. Yeah, who knew? And finally, Andy is surprised by how much he loves sitting in for Aaron at reception. Andy is a very good receptionist. Talk about the Peter principle. Exactly. He should have maybe just stayed right there. Well, fast fact number one,
在塔拉哈西这里，他真的把斯坦利当成了某种导师。对，谁能想到呢？最后，安迪惊奇地发现自己竟然那么喜欢代替艾琳在前台值班。安迪是个非常优秀的前台。真可以说是彼得原理的生动体现。一点没错。他也许真该就这么呆在那儿。好吧，趣味冷知识一号，
we shot this episode after a two week Thanksgiving hiatus. So if I look like I'm moving more comfortably, that's because I was, I'd had this nice two week break. However, I was thinking back to this Thanksgiving Angela, over this Thanksgiving with my eight week old son, after coming off of being back at work and my C-section, I hosted my husband's family for Thanksgiving and insisted on making a pie from scratch,
我们在感恩节两周假期结束后拍摄了这一集。所以如果看起来我动起来更自如了，那是因为我确实如此，我度过了美妙的两周假期。不过，安吉拉，我回想起这个感恩节，在经历重返工作岗位和剖腹产后，面对我八周大的儿子，我招待了我丈夫的家人过感恩节，并且坚持要从头开始做派，
like a homemade pie crust, my first homemade pie crust. Why, why do we do this to ourselves? Why are we crazy? Why are we crazy? You lost me at hosted Thanksgiving. I know, with a newborn. With a eight week old, but it was my mother-in-law ginger's opportunity to come visit the baby.
比如自制派皮，我人生中第一个自制派皮。为什么，我们为什么要这样折磨自己？我们为什么这么疯狂？我们为什么这么疯狂？你从“招待感恩节”那句开始就把我整不会了。我知道，而且还是带着一个新生儿。带着一个八周大的宝宝，但这是我婆婆金格来看望宝宝的机会。
So we kind of bundled it and you know, I wasn't working for this two weeks. So it made it a little easier, but. Those were all the things you said to yourself at the time. But then here you are with a newborn, trying to make pie crust and you have a bunch of people coming over. And then when my son was 12 weeks old, we had my whole family and for Christmas. At your house, you hosted again?
所以我们把事情凑到了一起，你知道的，这两周我没上班。这让事情变得稍微容易了一点，但是。这些都是你当时自我安慰的话。但随后你带着一个新生儿，试图制作派皮，家里还要来一大帮人。然后当我儿子12周大时，我们全家又来过圣诞节。在你家里，你又招待大家了？
Yes. Oh my gosh. But listen, you know, people pitched in, my husband's sister made a bunch of dishes for Thanksgiving, my mom and sister made a bunch of stuff for Christmas. And it felt easier than packing up the baby and going on the road. Well, there's that. Yeah, but I remembered this when I was watching the episode
对。哦天哪。不过听着，你知道的，大家都有帮忙，我丈夫的姐姐为感恩节做了好几道菜，我妈妈和姐姐为圣诞节做了很多东西。而且这感觉比把宝宝打包带出门旅行要轻松。好吧，倒也是。对，当我看到这一集时我想起了这件事，
and I went back and I looked at a bunch of pictures. And then I Googled, what did you do over this Thanksgiving? Which I don't know why. I know you emailed me that you Googled Thanksgiving 2011. Yeah, and then put in my name. And what came up was this interview I did on Conan O'Brien. Which was so good. And, Angela, you had the most amazing hair. You had an incredible center part. I never see you do center part. I know. I was trying to do Elizabeth Shoe. Remember, like Elizabeth Elizabeth's shoe like cocktail era. Do it more.
然后我回去翻看了很多照片。接着我谷歌了一下，你在这个感恩节做了什么？我也不知道为什么。我知道你发邮件告诉我你谷歌了2011年的感恩节。对，然后输入了我的名字。跳出来的是我接受柯南·奥布莱恩采访的视频。那期节目太棒了。而且，安吉拉，你的发型美极了。你留了一个惊艳的中分。我从没见你留过中分。我知道。我当时在模仿伊丽莎白·苏。记得吗，就像伊丽莎白·苏在《鸡尾酒》那部电影里的造型。多留留嘛。
It becomes you. It was, yes, it was so good. And you talked about your Thanksgiving with your family. I did. And you guys, I have a little clip and it just made me smile so big because I had forgotten this. I mean, obviously, you know, when I heard it, I remembered. But my mom and dad had come out to visit.
非常适合你。真的，太棒了。而且你还谈到了你和家人过的感恩节。我是说过。大家，我有一个小剪辑，它让我笑得合不拢嘴，因为我都快忘光了。当然，你知道的，当我听到时我想起来了。但我爸妈曾来看望过我。
And my mom and dad and I took Isabel to the Santa Barbara Zoo and I talked about it. And then I found all these pictures of us at the zoo. And anyway, it just was a wonderful trip down the ring. I'm so glad you Googled Angela Thanksgiving. Here's a little bit from the interview. It's fine, but you're Thanksgiving. You have a nice Thanksgiving.
我爸妈和我带着伊莎贝尔去了圣巴巴拉动物园，我在节目里聊了这件事。然后我找到了所有我们在动物园的照片。总之，这是一次美妙的回忆之旅。我很高兴你谷歌了“安吉拉感恩节”。以下是采访的一小段。这很好，不过你的感恩节。你过了一个不错的感恩节。
I did. My mom and dad, Bill and Bertie Kinsey, Varture City, Texas. Nothing. No. That's OK. They came out and we took my daughter to the Santa Barbara Zoo. It's like so nice up there.
我过的很好。我爸妈，比尔和伯蒂·金西，来自得克萨斯州瓦图尔城。什么也没有。好吧。他们过来了，我们带着我女儿去了圣巴巴拉动物园。那里的环境非常优美。
It's a great zoo. It's a great zoo, right? And this is this happened. So a helicopter goes over. And my dad is like, he's the guy that informs people. So a helicopter goes over and my dad goes, we got a chopper. And I'm like, okay.
那是个很棒的动物园，是个很棒的动物园对吧？然后发生了这样一件事。一架直升机飞过。我爸就属于那种喜欢向别人通报情况的人。所以一架直升机飞过，我爸就说：“我们有直升机了。”然后我就想，好吧。
And my mom throws this away, goes, probably Angelina Joly going somewhere. They do that. Like if there's any traffic anywhere we are, she's probably Brad Pitt and those kids. Anytime they see a helicopter, they assume it's Brad and Angelina going somewhere? Yes, I'm like, mom, I don't think their lines
我妈把这事随口一说，来了句：“可能是安吉丽娜·朱莉要去哪儿吧。”他们总是这样。就好像我们无论在哪里遇到任何交通状况，她都会觉得那是布拉德·皮特和那些孩子。只要他们看到直升机，就觉得那是布拉德和安吉丽娜要去什么地方？是的，我就想，妈，我觉得他们的行程
are that fancy. I don't know. No, they probably are. It's them. Yeah, it's probably her. They've often taunted me from the helicopter. Look at that, Tyler. Look, yeah, exactly.
没有那么高调吧。我不知道。不，他们可能还真是。就是他们。对，可能真的是她。他们经常从直升机上嘲讽我。看那个，泰勒。看，对，没错。
Yeah, totally. Oh, I love that you have that like memory now and it's preserved. I know, you know, I actually showed my daughter the clip and she was like, mom! And she also commented on the middle part because it looks so good. And it's also very infasional the middle part and she's like, mom, I never knew you did a middle part. It's like, well, once or twice. Isn't there a whole like, Gen C, maleil thing where it's like, well, once or twice. Isn't there a whole like Gen Z,
对，完全是这样。哦，我很高兴你现在有了这样的记忆并且它被保留了下来。我知道，你知道的，我实际上把这个剪辑给我女儿看了，她当时就喊：“妈妈！”她还评论了我的中分发型，因为看起来太棒了。而且中分现在非常流行，她就说：“妈妈，我从来不知道你还留过中分。”我就说：“嗯，留过一两次。”难道不是有那种，整个Gen Z、
maleil thing where it's like side part means one thing and then like middle part is. That's your younger, basically. Oh, it is. The millennials are a center part and Gen Z are side part or Gen X are side part. I forget what we are, but we're side part. We're side part people.
千禧一代的梗，就是说……难道不是有整个Gen Z、千禧一代的梗，就是说……偏分代表某种含义，然后中分又是……那是针对年轻人的，基本上。哦，是的。千禧一代留中分，Gen Z或者Gen X留偏分。我忘了我们属于哪一代了，但我们是偏分一族。我们是偏分人。
We're side part. Wait, Cassie, do you have a middle part? I always switch it, but Gen Z say, if you don't do a middle part, you're old. No, so we're old. So middle part is where it, but what happens if you are old and you do a center part, are you trying to hard?
我们是偏分人。等等，卡西，你留的是中分吗？我总是换来换去，但Gen Z说，如果你不留中分，你就是老了。不，所以我们老了。所以中分才是王道，但是如果你已经老了还留中分，你是不是在刻意装嫩？
I mean, I think Gen Z wants you to do a middle part, but maybe to Tomacus. That's what I'm afraid of. Well, I rocked a middle part, and maybe I'll try it again. I think you should. Are you ready for fast fact number two? Because it's all about one of our favorite people. Catherine Tate as Nelly Bertram.
我是说，我觉得Gen Z是希望你留中分，但也许会觉得你是在东施效颦？我怕的就是这个。好吧，我曾驾驭过中分，也许我会再试一次。我觉得你应该。你准备好迎接趣味冷知识二号了吗？因为这全关于我们最喜欢的人之一。扮演内莉·伯特姆的凯瑟琳·泰特。
Catherine Tate, one of the funniest women I've ever been in a room with. I love her. So much. So much. So kind and nice. Okay, go. Here is what everyone needs to know. Catherine Tate is a superstar.
凯瑟琳·泰特，我共事过的最搞笑的女性之一。我太喜欢她了。真的非常喜欢。人超级好。好，继续。以下是每个人都应该知道的。凯瑟琳·泰特是个超级巨星。
She was on Doctor Who. She was on the Catherine Tate show in England. But she was relatively unknown in the United States when she came to do the office. But you have to imagine if like Carol Burnett went to England and then was on England's most popular show. That was Catherine Tate coming on our show. The writers absolutely fell in love with her cameo during Search Party and they wanted her to join the cast at the beginning of season 8, but she was doing a play in the West End, so she wasn't able to join us until mid-season. And we got a fan question from a Leonard S in Amsterdam,
她出演过《神秘博士》。她在英国出演过《凯瑟琳·泰特秀》。但她来到《办公室》时，在美国还相对默默无闻。不过你得想象一下，如果卡罗尔·伯内特去英国，然后参演了英国最受欢迎的节目。那就是凯瑟琳·泰特加盟我们的节目。编剧们在《寻人派对》客串期间绝对爱上了她，他们希望她在第八季开始时就加入演员阵容，但她当时正在西区出演一出话剧，所以直到季中她才能加入我们。我们收到了来自荷兰阿姆斯特丹的伦纳德·S发来的一个粉丝提问，
Netherlands, who asked, was it confirmed that Catherine Tate would become a series regular before filming the Tallahassee episode? Well Steve Burgess said, all we knew at this point was that we were going to have her for the rest of season eight. We had her contracted for 10 episodes, but we really hoped that it would be more. From the beginning, right, we wanted her. Everyone wanted her. Now, I was reading a lot about what the writers had to say about her coming in and her character
他问：在拍摄塔拉哈西那一集之前，是否已经确认凯瑟琳·泰特会成为常驻演员？嗯，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，我们当时唯一确定的就是我们将在第八季剩下的时间里拥有她。我们跟她签了10集的合约，但我们真的很希望会更多。从一开始，对吧，我们就想要她。每个人都想要她。现在，我读了很多关于编剧们对她加入以及她的角色的看法的文章，
in Andy Green's book about the office. And basically, all the writers kind of apologized for not using her enough as her arc went on. I'll be very curious to watch that because in this episode, she is absolutely fantastic. And I want to track her arc. But that was the general consensus was we got an absolute comedic superstar in this woman. And in the end, they felt like they didn't write to her enough that they didn't give her storyline
在安迪·格林关于《办公室》的书里。基本上，所有编剧在她的角色发展过程中都对没有充分利用她表达了某种歉意。我很想看看那一集，因为在这集中，她绝对是太棒了。我想追踪她的角色弧光。但当时的共识是，我们在这位女性身上得到了一个绝对的喜剧巨星。最后，他们觉得没有为她写足够多的戏份，没有给她的故事线
enough of the spotlight. So we'll see. I can't remember. You know, I ran into Catherine a few years ago, total coincidence. We saw each other. We got to talking and it was just so great catching up with her. And I really want to have her on the podcast. Oh, for sure. I think she gets her whole own episode. Oh, yes. Right. All right. Moving on now to fast fact number three. Angela, you told me you have a share and you know I love it when you take over fast fact number three, so I can't wait. Yes, did you know, Jenna, that there is a really big, the office mural being painted in Scranton? Right now? Right now?
足够的聚光灯。所以我们拭目以待。我记不太清了。你知道的，几年前我偶遇了凯瑟琳，纯属巧合。我们见到了彼此。我们聊了起来，叙旧的感觉真是太棒了。我真的很想邀请她来播客做客。哦，那当然。我觉得她值得拥有一整期专属节目。哦，没错。没错。好的，现在我们进入趣味冷知识三号。安吉拉，你告诉我你有一个分享，你知道我最喜欢你接管趣味冷知识三号了，所以我迫不及待了。是的，你知道吗，珍妮弗，斯克兰顿正在绘制一幅非常巨大的《办公室》壁画？就在现在？就在现在？
Oh, yes. According to the new station WNEP, listen to this title, Ain't no mural like an office mural. What is on the office mural? This says, Everyone, stay calm. The new mural coming to Lackawanna Avenue will feature some fan favorite characters and in parentheses and also Toby. That's clever. Scranton is well known for being the setting of the popular television show The Office, and that's why a new mural is coming to Lackawanna Avenue.
哦，是的。根据WNEP新闻台的报道，听听这个标题：“没有哪个壁画能比得上《办公室》壁画。”《办公室》壁画上画了什么？上面写着：“大家，保持冷静。即将亮相拉克万纳大道的全新壁画将以一些粉丝最喜爱的角色为特色，括号里写着：还有托比。”这太聪明了。斯克兰顿因作为热门电视剧《办公室》的背景地而闻名遐迩，这就是为什么一幅新壁画即将登陆拉克万纳大道。
When it's finished, it will be 86 feet wide. That seems large. I know. And 27 feet tall. The mural will feature portraits of your favorite dundermiflin employees, local landmarks referenced in the series, and famous quotes from the show. And famous quotes. Yes.
当它完工时，它将有86英尺宽。听起来很大。我知道。还有27英尺高。这幅壁画将描绘你最喜欢的邓德米夫林员工的肖像、剧中提及的当地地标，以及剧中的名言。还有名言。是的。
Wow, that's a lot of stuff, but I mean it's a large billboard. It sounds like it'll fit. A formal dedication of the mural is set for October 6th. That's like next week. I know. We've got to go. I mean, I know we can't get there for next week. I know, I know we can't up and go right now, but I'm just saying,
哇，内容真多，不过我的意思是这是一块巨大的广告牌。听起来装得下。这幅壁画的正式落成仪式定于10月6日。那就像是下周。我知道。我们得去。我的意思是，我知道我们下周赶不到那里。我知道，我知道我们不能说走就走，但我的意思是，
lady, when we go to Scranton, we gotta go to the mural. Well, of course I'm taking a picture of myself in front of this mural. In front of yourself. On a mural. I want to imagine that Pam painted it. Oh, just gonna pretend she did. Oh, I like that.
亲爱的，当我们去斯克兰顿的时候，我们一定要去看这幅壁画。当然，我一定要在这幅壁画前给自己拍张照。站在你自己的照片前。在一幅壁画上。我要假装是帕姆画的。哦，就假装是她画的。哦，我喜欢这样。
Pam painted it. Angela looked on judging. But anyway, we're super excited to check out this mural in Scranton, Pennsylvania, and oh my goodness, how wonderful the city of Scranton has been to us as a cast. So true. We love you guys. Well, before we had to break, just a quick reminder that we will be in Toronto next Thursday, September 21st, as part of the Just For Laughs Festival. There are still tickets available, and we would love to see you there. Yes, you can find tickets at Toronto.ha-ha-ha.com.
帕姆画的。安吉拉在一旁评头论足。不过无论如何，我们都超级兴奋去看看宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿的这幅壁画，哦天哪，斯克兰顿这座城市作为演员对我们实在是太好了。千真万确。我们爱你们。好吧，在我们休息之前，温馨提醒大家，我们将于下周四，即9月21日前往多伦多，作为“随性大笑”喜剧节的一部分。还有门票在售，我们非常希望能在那见到你们。是的，你们可以在 Toronto.ha-ha-ha.com 买到票。
That's H-A-H-A-H-A.com, and we hope you can join us. It's a really fun night of friendship and embarrassing stories. Lots of those. Bring your best friend. go with your mom, go with your dad, go with your partner in life. We can't wait to see you. Well, that's all I got. Should we take a break and then come back
网址是 H-A-H-A-H-A.com，我们希望你能加入我们。这将是一个充满友谊和尴尬故事的有趣夜晚。多得是这种故事。带上你最好的朋友去，和你的妈妈一起去，和你的爸爸一起去，和你的生活伴侣一起去。我们迫不及待地想见到你们。好吧，我的分享就这些。我们是不是该休息一下然后回来，
and we can discuss how Dwight wakes people up in the morning? It's not pleasant. No, it's not. You better wake up because Dwight is coming around. Yes, he goes one by one and he wakes up everybody in different ways. He's got it perfectly timed out. It's all starting at 5.10 in the morning. Well, yeah, he gives a breakdown of how long it's going to take to get everyone moving
讨论一下德怀特早上是怎么叫醒大家的？这可一点都不愉快。不，一点也不。你最好醒醒，因为德怀特要来了。没错，他一个接一个地用不同的方式叫醒每个人。他把时间掐得死死的。这一切都从早上5点10分开始。好吧，是的，他详细说明了早上让每个人都动起来需要花多长时间。
in the morning. As he has this monologue where he breaks down how he has to wake everyone up at different times, did you notice how Dwight gets dressed? Please tell me there was a fan mail flurry. No. What? How he gets dressed. He is getting dressed as he does this monologue.
当他发表这段独白，详细讲述他必须在不同时间叫醒每个人时，你有没有注意到德怀特是怎么穿衣服的？快告诉我有大批粉丝来信。没有。什么？他是怎么穿衣服的。他在做这段独白的 同时把衣服穿好了。他同时穿上衬衫和西装外套。他把衬衫塞进了西装外套里。所以当他把任何一件……当他伸进一只胳膊时，他实际上是把胳膊伸进了两件衣服里。然后他的袜子完美地摆放在鞋子里，这样当他把脚伸进去时，袜子就自动穿进鞋里了。我在这段面对镜头独白时在干嘛呢？最近，他有很多事情要做。他得能做点什么才行。他得能做点什么才行。他得能做点什么才行。他得能做点什么才行。
He puts his shirt and blazer on at the same time. He has his shirt tucked into his blazer. So when he puts any of those. When he puts one arm in, he's actually putting his arm through two items of clothing. Then his socks are perfectly laid out in his shoe so that when he puts his foot in his socket automatically goes in his shoe. What was I doing during this talking head? Lately, he's got a lot of stuff to do. He's got to be able to do something. He's got to be able to do something. He's got to be able to do something. He's got to be able to do something.
他得能做点什么才行。他得能做点什么才行。他得能做点什么才行。他得能做点什么才行。他得能做点什么才行。他得能做点什么才行。他得能做点什么才行。他得能做点什么才行。他穿的衣服跟别的东西连在一起。哇，真不敢相信我竟然错过了。
He's got to be able to do something. He's got to be able to do something. He's got to be able to do something. He's got to be able to do something. He's got to be able to do something. He's got to be able to do something. He's got to be able to do something. He's got to be able to do something. He's got on is attached to something else. Wow, I can't believe I missed it.
I thought it was brilliant. I love this little piece of detail. Well, Dwight's going to wake up Kathy by yelling in her ear, and scaring her. Then he tries to do the same thing to Aaron, but Aaron is sleeping with her feet on her pillow and wax him in the head. Then they try to wake up Stanley, because now Aaron's helping him, but Stanley won't wake up, so Dwight basically holds his nose and closes his mouth. That is terrifying. Can you imagine waking up like that? I cannot.
Then they go into wake up Ryan, and Aaron kinda is like, hey, wanna wake up? Ryan is so excited. Apparently he went to her door twice the night before. Then he realizes it's just Dwight trying to wake wake him up and he's like, not cool. Last person they go to wake up is Jim, but Jim's been up for a long time. He's on a two-kid sleep schedule.
I would like to play a bullsh** card real quick. Okay. In Dwight's talking head, he says that Jim takes 50 minutes to style his hair. Uh-huh. Shouldn't he have woken Jim up first? According to his talking head, Jim needs the most time in the morning. Why is he the last room they go to?
Dwight, I accept your bullsh**t card. Thank you. I was curious about the scene, you know, Jim's elaborate prank of how he's trying to fake his own death and they walk into the room. Yes, and framed Dwight for it. Exactly. I his own death and they walk into the room. Yes, and framed white for it. Exactly. I was curious how it was described in the script. This is what it said. Camera turns to reveal that Jim has set up the room to look like an insane crime scene.
There's an open briefcase with money spilling out of it. A blood-soaked towel in the corner. The mattress is overturned. The TV is set to static. The balcony door is open. There are sheets tied into a rope going over the balcony's edge. Now, here's something that I found really interesting about this scene, which is that in reality when Dwight and Aaron walk into the room, they would have taken in all of these details,
probably at the same time. For example, the sign on the wall that says Dwight did it. They might have seen that first, but they wait to react until the camera has panned around the room and ends on Dwight did it and then they react to it, which I just thought was really interesting because we are assuming that they saw the room the way the camera saw the room. But really, if you walk in a room,
you see it all at once, right? Mm-hmm. I just thought that was interesting story telling maneuver. I feel like you're calling Bullshit on a few things today. I feel like I call Bullshit on the camera work. No, it's just, I guess it would be like on the delayed reaction of Dwight and Aaron. I feel like they would have reacted much sooner, but they had to wait for the camera to get to the sign. Exactly.
Well, this whole cold-open Angela took me down a road that is very random. I got curious about how early do you need to wake up in the morning before you can walk out the door? How long does the average person need in the morning? And I actually found an article that was on Glamour Magazine's website, and it broke down the average amount of time that both men and women need for grooming in the morning. Oh, let's hear it. Does this interest you?
It does because just this morning, I sort of shared that I am done maintaining the back of my head. Okay. I'm done. How much time will this save you? I'm hoping quite a bit because I have a calic in the back of my head and I have to back home and I have to hairspray. I have to do things so the red sea
doesn't part back there every day. Right. And I'm done. I'm done. You know what? If you see me out and about and you see the back of my head looking like a hot mess, just know that I'm done. It's intentional.
I'm done. Okay. Good to know. The back of my head looks quite wonky lately because of my shoulder. So we're quite a pair. That would be our paparazzi photo. Like no one's seeing pictures of us like who cares. But when I'd love to see out there is just a photo of the back of our heads. Just looking horrible. One can dream. Well, Horrible. Ah, one can dream. Well, according to this article by Glamour magazine, the average time that a woman spends on grooming in the morning is 22.5 minutes, and men average 20 minutes.
However, they pointed to a study that said that the longer someone spends getting ready in the morning, the more likely they are to feel negative about their appearance. Oh, but the less time you spend grooming in the morning, the more positively they view their appearance. And I was thinking about that. I'm like, you know what? I have to say it kind of makes sense to me because the more time I spend scrutinizing in front of a mirror, the less confident I feel. So I do kind of like to just get that morning routine over with. I think for me, it changed as I aged, you know? Because here I am 52 and I'm like,
I'm done taking care of the back of my head. Right? When I was younger, I spent more time trying to look nice. Same. And I was giving up. I don't know. Well, I think for me in terms of grooming, I need 12 minutes to pull myself together, 20,
if I'm trying hard. But in general, as I get older, I like a real long runway in the morning. I like to ease into my day slowly. So, do I need to wake me up like a good 90 minutes before he wants me to be like participating in a work day, I think. Yeah. Dwight doesn't want to come wake me up. He doesn't? No.
Oh boy. Don't come at me Dwight, not in the morning. I do want to say the way that John as Jim fell out of the closet, I thought was so good. We got a fan question about that. Olga in Spain said, was it really John or was it a doll? Like it was John. It was John. But he fell so convincingly. It looked like it hurt. It looked perfect.
He went noodle. He did. It was very well done. It was John. Yeah. The episode is going to start now with Jim. He's in the lobby gift shop. It looks like of the hotel. He is. And Dwight's trying to get everyone, you know, out the door into the van. The scene was much longer. It's in the deleted scenes. Aaron actually goes up to Jim and is like, well, what do you like better? Stuffed animals are puppets. And Aaron has strong opinions about this. Oh, Jim was not ready for.
Is it puppets? She said puppets because there's stuffed animals that can actually do something. I was curious about this Tallahassee gift shop at the hotel. Mm-hmm. I love a gift shop. I know. I love it.
I'm gonna bring you back something. If I go somewhere, I'm bringing you back something. This gift shop had mostly alligators, parrot puppets, lollipops, and flip flops. Okay, this made me very curious about what Tallahassee has to offer. Should I settle in for a Tallahassee breakdown? I've found so many interesting things about Tallahassee
that I'm actually gonna sprinkle them throughout the episode. Okay, but first up, Tallahassee that I'm actually going to sprinkle them throughout the episode. Okay. But first up, Tallahassee is the state capital of Florida. It has two Ls, two Ss and two E's, which also got me curious about what other double letter U.S. state capitals there are. Can you name any? Sam, Cassie. Feel free to jump in. Well, I mean, I just thought of Mississippi, but that is a state. State capital, double letters. Buffalo has two Fs in it.
Is it the state capital of Newark? No. Albany is. Yeah. I would say little rock. Yes, Sam! Very good. Ready?
What? Are you gonna say more? Do you wanna do I have to keep showing off my lack of geographic knowledge? I'll just read what the internet said. Nashville Little Rock, Harrisburg, Annapolis, Cheyenne, Pierre, and Jefferson City. Oh my gosh.
I'm ashamed. Jefferson City is the capital of Missouri. Lady. I mean, I knew that. But I wasn't thinking of the double ass. Double mothers. I know. Yeah. Also, did you know that the distance from Tallahassee to the Georgia state line is about 17 miles? I didn't. And 58 miles from the Alabama state line. Well, those are very good facts, Angela. There's more to come. Oh, good.
Well, I will wait for them. Just so everyone knows, we did not film this in Tallahassee. We filmed in Valencia, California. Steve Burgess said we shot in the lobby, interior hotel rooms, and exterior valet all at the Hyatt Regency in Valencia. It is still there. We also took over basically the whole second floor of the hotel, and that's where we shot the hotel rooms, but our crew members also had hotel rooms for their stuff. So like craft service was in room 258. Oh, if you wanted a snack, that's where
you went. The sound department had 246. Here in makeup and wardrobe was in room 239. There was also a cast green room. All of the cast trailers were out in the parking lot, but once you got to the quote-unquote set, which was this hotel, this is where the departments would kind of hang in between and keep their stuff. However, the conference room that you're going to see later, that was not at the hotel, we built that on our stages. I remember that conference room. You do? I do, because I always love to go see what they were building. You know, I do my walks with Oscar, and then we would just go kind of pop in.
Oh, yeah. Dwight has a talking head where he shares that first impressions can last forever, so he really needs Nelly to see him as a leader. Yes, this is where he says that the first day he met Pam, I guess she did something that rubbed him the wrong way, and even though she has been nothing but wonderful ever since. He hates her. Yeah, but he's, he also's like, you know,
I work with her, I like her, but I also hate her. Yeah, because of this one thing that happened on the first day. There was a must shoot alt for this Dwight talking head. And I want to share it with you, okay? The first day is when group dynamics are set. I had a bad first day of kindergarten, and for the next 13 years, I was seen as some weird outcast.
So if I don't show Nelly today that I'm the natural leader, I might as well stick my penis in the finger paints. Oh my goodness. Okay, obviously we cannot use that talking head. Obviously, I'm sure they had fun writing it. I know. But that is not going on the air.
That is ridiculous. It made me laugh so because everything was normal about it to the last few words. And then I was like, what? I know. Well, Dwight's going to head to the gift shop. He needs to pick up some anacids and he wants to buy a gift for baby Philip. And he's gonna have a chat with Heather, the gift shop worker who was played by Trish Sir. Now Trish is one of
the co-hosts of the show Clean House, where every week a team of people comes and declutters a house. Oh, I need them. She was the yard sale, Diva. She won a daytime Emmy for this show. Yeah, wow. And she was really good in this episode too. But yes, Dwight is really taking his paternity of Philip very seriously. Next up is a very funny beat where Ryan is having Aaron take pictures of him for Facebook. There was more to this. It's in deleted scenes where he does poses around the parking lot. Oh, it's really funny. Dwight starts chowing down an acid tablets and then Stanley rolls up in a shiny red convertible. He invites Jim to ride with him and says Jim,
you can control the iPod. Old tech alert. Yep. And Stanley requests Kinney Logins. This is one of my favorite couplets of dialogue in the whole entire episode because it is so subtle and I loved it. Stanley says, you're a nice guy Jim, but you have no idea how to vacation. Find some Kinney Logins. Jim says, logins and Messina. Stanley says, did I say Messina? And he pills out.
Okay, I didn't get it because I don't know what logins and Messina is. Okay. Kenny logins and Jim Messina were a singer, songwriter duo. They had tons of hits. You probably know, I mean, I know you know them. They're the song, um, Danny song. Oh my gosh, I'm horrible singer, but it's like, even though we ain't got money, I'm so in love with you, honey. Oh, I love that song. Oh my gosh, I'm horrible singer, but it's like even though we ain't got money. I'm so in love with you honey. Oh, I love that song. Okay, that one That's logins in Messina. That's logins in Messina. Also your mom don't dance and daddy don't rock and roll. That's logins in Messina. They had so many hands. I love them, but clearly Stanley does not want logins in Messina. He wants just straight up solo Lagan's.
You know, can he Lagan's, he did a bunch of songs. I mean, what solo Lagan? I, oh, you know what, top gun. What's the top gun song? Ride in into the danger zone. I probably would have picked Lagan's and Messina. I think I'm Lagan's and Messina too. And I didn't even know it.
I didn't even know who this Missine a fellow was. It just cracked me up. Like, I don't know which writer in the writer's room pitched this very small subtle joke that Stanley would not like Missine and only want solo logins. But it really cracked me up. You guys, I'm a total dork for little tiny jokes like that.
Well, I noticed something about this scene which is that it was very windy outside. Did you see the wind? So windy. No, I think I was so fixated on that couple of dialogue. Well, I noticed it because that's kind of unusual for LA, but I thought it really sold it as Florida. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Made it look very tropical. Yeah. Well, these guys are all going to head to their meeting, and in the meantime, we're going to head to Scranton. Andy's going to walk out of his office and notice how incredibly quiet it is.
Yeah, Creed likes it. He's already written 12th plays. Yeah. Can we please, please, have an episode somewhere where we just watch one of Creed's plays? Why didn't that exist? Because it would be utter nonsense. I know. It would make no sense. Pam wonders, wait, why is it so quiet? She realizes that it's because no one took the phone off voicemail. The phone hasn't
been ringing. And as soon as she takes the phone off voice mail, it rings immediately, and now who's gonna answer it? All of a sudden, there's this front reception standoff between Andy and Pam. And Kelly's freaking out, she's like, someone just answer it. Neither of them want a budge. There was a Pam deleted talking head that would have gone here, and I want to read it to you.
Please. I remember it. Here's what Pam said. I just got back from eternity leave. I can't let them make me the receptionist. I've worked way too hard for way too long to get to this place. Of them thinking, I'm the office administrator.
Yes. We got a piece of mail about the scene from Charlotte E. in Canada, but who is living in the UK. Charlotte said, I just want to say how much I appreciate the scene where Pam does not pick up the phone in the end. Charlotte said, I just want to say how much I appreciate the scene where Pam does not pick up the phone in the end, because that's not her job anymore. There's so much underlying expectations sometimes
in an office environment, and as someone who moved from a support team role to a non-support team role in my current job, you've got to stand your ground and kindly redirect people to the right person when they look to you to buy milk or find a power cord. Those were very specific examples, Charlotte. Anyway, Charlotte goes on to say, it's not about not being a team player,
but about the subtle implication that their time is more important than my time, just because you once took care of those housekeeping things. Anyway, I was just willing, willing Pam not to pick up the phone and I'm so glad when she didn't. Well Charlotte, I also like that Pam stood her ground for all these reasons. However, it does feel like reception is maybe part of Pam's quote unquote department
但关于那种微妙的暗示，即他们的时间比我的时间更重要，只因为你曾经处理过那些杂务。总之，我当时真的很希望，非常希望帕姆不要接电话，她没接，我太高兴了。好吧，夏洛特，我也喜欢帕姆出于所有这些原因坚持自己的立场。不过，感觉前台也许确实是帕姆所谓的部门的一部分
and with both the temp and the receptionist gone, it feels like she's the last person left in that department and maybe probably maybe should have answered the phone. I mean, yes, yes, I think so. I support Pam's stance of not answering the phones because it will set a precedent. But yeah, it is her department. And if she's not going to answer the phone, I believe she's responsible for finding someone to answer the phone. There it is. Right? Yes. Next up, Jim tells Kathy that Stanley drives fast and Stanley explains that life is short and one of his motto is drive fast, leave a sexy corpse. We had a fan question from Charlotte M. in Washington, DC, who said, I have been
现在临时工和前台都不在了，感觉她是那个部门剩下的最后一个人，也许，可能真的应该接电话。我是说，对，对，我也这么觉得。我支持帕姆不接电话的立场，因为这会开创一个先例。但是，是的，这确实是她的部门。如果她不打算接电话，我认为她有责任找别人来接电话。就是这样。对吧？是的。接下来，吉姆告诉凯茜，斯坦利开车很快，斯坦利解释说人生苦短，他的人生信言之一就是：开车要快，留下一具性感的尸体。我们收到了来自华盛顿特区的夏洛特·M的粉丝提问，她说：我
waiting for so long to send in this question. This is my top Stanley line in the whole series. Were there any candy bag ults? I went to the candy bag. I did too. I didn't see any no ults. And this line was scripted exactly the way he said it. Yes.
等了这么久才把这个问题发过来。这是整部剧里我最喜欢的斯坦利台词。有什么糖果袋里的绝招吗？我去看了糖果袋。我也是。我没看到任何绝招。而且这台词就是按他说的原样写在剧本里的。对。
But it did make me want to know if Stanley had any other mottos. I wish that there was like just a writer's pit sheet of Stanley mottos. I'm sure it exists somewhere. I was actually going to ask you about the show Bible. If it said anything in the show Bible. If there was a page called Stanley's mottos, I believe there is not.
但这确实让我很想知道斯坦利还有没有别的信言。我真希望有什么编剧的斯坦利信言小抄。我确信这东西在某处是存在的。我其实正想问你关于剧集圣经的事。剧集圣经里有没有提到这个。有没有哪一页叫“斯坦利的信言”，我觉得是没有的。
I wish there was. Guess who Stanley's Modo's, I believe there is not. I wish there was. Guess who else is at this conference? The Pac-Man is back. Jim and Dwight tried to get him fired, but he landed on his feet in Florida. Yeah, he's got nine lives and a nine inches of other things. Yep. Now we get to introduce Nelly Bertram,
我希望有。猜猜谁是斯坦利的信言……我觉得是没有的。我希望有。猜猜还有谁在这个会议上？吃豆人又回来了！吉姆和德怀特试图让他被炒鱿鱼，但他在佛罗里达站稳了脚跟。是的，他有九条命，还有九英寸的其他东西。没错。现在我们要介绍内莉·伯特曼了，
one of my favorite introductions. Ever! I love how she just selects Ryan. And just starts whispering to him and also Ryan doesn't question it. He just starts saying what she's telling him to say. Yes, what does she get Ryan to say? She says, say, so who's leading this thing anyway? Say, I can't wait to meet him. Yes. say, so who's leading this thing anyway?
这是我最喜欢的出场之一。简直史上最佳！我太喜欢她径直走向瑞安的方式了。然后就开始对他耳语，而且瑞安也没有质疑。他只是开始说她让他说的话。没错，她让瑞安说了什么？她说：说吧，到底是谁在领导这玩意儿？说：我等不及要见他了。是的。说吧，到底是谁在领导这玩意儿？
Say, I can't wait to meet him. Yes. And then she stands up and says, him, you say, don't think a woman could be a leader? You poor simple boy. Yes. And then she launches into a speech, and I want to ask you, Angela, if I'm ever asked to do like a commencement speech
说：我等不及要见他了。是的。然后她站起来说：他，你说？不认为女人能当领导？你这个可怜的单纯男孩。是的。然后她开始长篇大论，我想问你，安吉拉，如果我以后有机会做类似毕业典礼演讲
at my college or at college. Can I start my speech like this? Can I do this? Expected a man, did you? Strong, powerful, huge, whopping penis? Well, sorry to disappoint, but my huge whopping penis is right here, then I point to my brain. And I'm not afraid to use it.
在我的大学里，或者在大学里。我能这样开始我的演讲吗？我可以这样做吗？以为是个男人，对吧？坚定、强壮、巨大、硕大无比的阴茎？好吧，很抱歉让你们失望了，但我那硕大无比的阴茎就在这里，然后我指向我的脑子。而且我敢用它。
So stop looking at my breasts and start looking at my penis. Can I start it that way? Will people get it? That would be amazing. Can I? I really want to know. I want you to do it. There is going to be an event,
所以别盯着我的胸看，开始盯着我的阴茎看吧。我能用这种方式开场吗？大家能懂吗？那太棒了。我可以吗？我真的很想知道。我想让你这么干。有一个活动，
and I'm going to start it that way. And we'll see how it goes. There's going to be a whole ton of people that don't get it and think you've lost it. I know. And then there'll be like a few people in the corner that are like, woohoo. Season eight, tell us.
我要用这种方式开场。然后我们看看效果如何。肯定会有一大堆人完全不懂，还以为你疯了。我知道。然后角落里大概会有那么几个人说，呜呼。第八季，快告诉我们。
So Nelly, yes, is now running the meeting. She's going to explain the origin of this project, which is that she interviewed to be the potential branch manager in Scranton. She points right at Jim and says, but I didn't get the job. And apparently she got really upset about this and went on a shopping spree. She bought 13 pianos. So all of this, when she's explaining her breakdown and how she bought the pianos and
所以内莉，是的，现在正在主持会议。她要解释这个项目的起源，也就是她面试过斯克兰顿分公司经理的职位。她直接指向吉姆说：但我没得到这份工作。显然她为此非常难过，于是去疯狂购物。她买下了13架钢琴。所以所有这些，当她解释自己的崩溃以及她是怎么买下钢琴的，还有
then how she had the sepiphany about selling things and she she bought the pianos and then how she had the supiphany about selling things and she went and talked to Joe and then she got the job. It was so well done that I went to the script because I wanted to know how much of it was scripted and maybe did Catherine improvise. It was scripted word for word. That is how good she is.
然后她是如何对销售豁然开朗的，以及她买下了钢琴，然后她是如何对销售豁然开朗的，然后她去跟乔谈话，最后她得到了这份工作。这一切做得太好了，以至于我特意去翻了剧本，因为我想知道有多少是剧本写好的，凯特琳是不是即兴发挥了。剧本里就是一字不差地写着的。这就是她的厉害之处。
Yeah. I thought she was literally coming up with half that stuff on the fly. That just shows I feel like when we have good writing and then a great performer, how just magic. Watching Catherine in the scene, I totally lost where I was. Mm-hmm. And if I had been in that conference room, I would have forgotten to act because I was just so enthralled with her performance. I wish it would have gone on another five minutes, like I could have watched even more of that.
对。我还以为她那些东西有一半都是临场发挥的呢。这恰恰说明，我觉得当我们有好的剧本，再加上一个伟大的演员时，那种化学反应简直太神奇了。看着凯特琳在这个场景里的表现，我完全忘了自己身在何处。嗯嗯。如果我当时在那个会议室里，我肯定会忘记怎么演戏，因为我完全被她的表演迷住了。我真希望这段能再演个五分钟，我简直能看更多这样的内容。
Well, lady, I think we should take a break before we get too deep into Dwight's appendicitis and Andy's obsession with reception. And when we come back, I actually have some interesting details on how this episode was received by fans and critics. There was a lot of hubbub. Did Miles McNutt write about it? He did, and I'm going to tell you what he said. Okay.
好了，女士，我觉得我们应该在深入讨论德怀特的阑尾炎和安迪对前台的痴迷之前休息一下。等我们回来，我其实有一些关于这一集是如何受到粉丝和评论家欢迎的有趣细节。当时可是引起了轩然大波。迈尔斯·麦克纳特写过关于它的文章吗？他写了，而且我会告诉你他是怎么说的。好的。
All right, we are back. And before we keep breaking down this episode, I thought maybe you might be interested to know how this episode Tallahassee was received. I'm so interested. Alright, it was very mixed. But it was sort of everybody versus Miles McNut. Oh yeah? Okay, so TV equals did a review of this episode
好吧，我们回来了。在我们继续剖析这一集之前，我想你可能会对这一集《塔拉哈西》是怎么受到欢迎的感兴趣。我太感兴趣了。好吧，反响非常混杂。但这有点像所有人对阵迈尔斯·麦克纳特。是吗？好吧，TV Equals对这一集做了评论
and said it was one of the best episodes of the season and maybe even of the last couple of seasons. Wow. Among Office Tally fans, Tallahassee was ranked number one for season eight, the number one episode, most favorite, among fans on Office Tally. Of all of season eight, of all of season eight. However, Miles McNut, not a fan,
并说这是本季最好的剧集之一，甚至可能是过去几季中最好的。哇。在Office Tally的粉丝中，《塔拉哈西》在第八季中排名第一，是最受欢迎的第一名，在Office Tally的粉丝中。在整个第八季中，在整个第八季中。然而，迈尔斯·麦克纳特并不喜欢，
gave it a C minus. Hmm. Here's a quote. While I left last week's episode with a sense of hope, Tallahassee has lived up to none of that potential. And you can imagine the rest of the review from there. Yeah.
给了它一个C减。嗯。这里有一段引言：“虽然我带着一丝希望结束了上一集的观看，但《塔拉哈西》没有兑现任何这种潜力。”你完全可以想象剩下的评论是什么样的。是啊。
Well, he got some pushback. A fan named Steve B wrote on the comment board, quote, I think you need to recuse yourself from viewing this show. Each week you find a new reason to hate a particular episode. When the show gives you what you want, you find another reason. For the last two seasons, you've been hitting the drumbeat of character-based comedy pretty hard. Yet here we have an episode that hinges largely on Dwight's characterization, his belligerence ambition, paranoia, and contempt for the common man,
好吧，他遭到了一些反弹。一个名叫史蒂夫·B的粉丝在评论板上写道，引述如下：“我认为你需要回避这部剧的观看。每周你都能找到一个新的理由去讨厌某一个特定剧集。当剧集给你你想要的东西时，你又会找出另一个理由。在过去的两个赛季里，你一直在猛烈抨击以角色为基础的喜剧。然而在这里，我们有一集很大程度上依赖于德怀特的性格塑造、他的好斗野心、偏执，以及对普通人的蔑视，
and it was a funny episode. Well, guess what? What? In his review, for after hours, which is next week's episode, Miles McNutt said this. Did he address Steve B? Well, sort of. Miles said, quote, Sort of. Miles said quote, last week's episode probably should have been above a C- Oh, but I went with my gut and I have to stand by that decision. Go Miles! I support him standing by his first reaction. Yes, that was his first reaction. I'll tell you among fans, generally they loved this episode, but the cold open was hotly debated. There was a huge lover hate of the cold open. We got a letter from Dennis D. in Tallahassee, Florida, who said, my favorite prank in the show is this episode's cold open.
但这却是一集很好笑的剧。”好吧，你猜怎么着？什么？在他对下一集的评论中，也就是下周的剧集《加班》里，迈尔斯·麦克纳特这么说了。他回应史蒂夫·B了吗？嗯，算是吧。迈尔斯说，引述如下：算是吧。迈尔斯说，引述如下：“上一集的评分大概应该在C以上，但我遵从了自己的直觉，我必须坚持这个决定。”加油，迈尔斯！我支持他坚持自己的第一反应。是的，那是他的第一反应。我跟你说，在粉丝中，大家总体上非常喜欢这一集，但片头相当受争议。关于片头，大家有巨大的爱恨交织。我们收到了一封来自佛罗里达州塔拉哈西的丹尼斯·D的信，他说：我在剧中最喜欢的恶作剧就是这一集的片头。
But the message boards regarding this cold open, when the show show aired one person said they deleted the episode from their DVR after watching the cold open because they hated it so much. Wow But then other people said it was the funniest cold open in a long time. They agreed with Dennis. You can't make everybody happy You can't you especially can't make miles but not happy very easily. I have to wonder and I'm sure it's not Is Steve B? Steve Burgess? Wait. Wait, that is so funny.
但是关于这个片头的留言板，在剧集播出时，有一个人说他们在看完片头后从DVR里删掉了这一集，因为他们太讨厌它了。哇。但接着其他人说这是很长一段时间以来最好笑的片头。他们同意丹尼斯的看法。你无法让所有人满意。你不能，你尤其无法轻易让迈尔斯·麦克纳特满意。我不得不怀疑，而且我确信不是这样，史蒂夫·B是史蒂夫·伯吉斯吗？等等。等等，太搞笑了。
Did Steve Burgess go on Miles McNutz reveal? I'm sure he did it because he's busy and he would probably never would have done that. He's running our show. But it is kind of funny that it's Steve B. I didn't even think of that Angela. I kind of want to ask Steve. I know, I do too.
史蒂夫·伯吉斯去过迈尔斯·麦克纳特的影评区吗？我确信他没去，因为他很忙，而且他可能永远不会做那种事。他在运营我们的节目呢。但奇怪的是他是史蒂夫·B，这挺有意思的。我甚至都没想到这一点，安吉拉。我有点想问问史蒂夫。我知道，我也想。
Did you ever write on Miles McNouth's comment board? Oh, I love that so much. And ask him to recuse himself. Well, I want to point out this next scene because, you know, Dwight is really popping the anacids now. He's in major pain. He is. And Nelly is going to ask someone to help with the projection screen to pull it down.
你有没有在迈尔斯·麦克纳特的评论区留言过？哦，我太喜欢这个了。然后叫他回避。嗯，我想指出接下来这个场景，因为，你知道的，德怀特现在在大把吃抗酸药。他正处于剧痛之中。他是的。内莉打算找个人来帮忙把投影幕布拉下来。
She points out that Ryan couldn't reach it. It would be so funny if he tried. My balloon. And it's in this moment that Dwight's like, I must appear like a strong tall leader, especially because she asked Jim to do it, right? I have to say, Rain Wilson completely crushed it. The way he sold his pain as he reaches up for that screen to pull it down, I thought he
她指出瑞安够不着。如果他试了那可就太搞笑了。我的气球。正是在这个时刻，德怀特心里想：我必须表现得像个强大高大的领导，特别是当她让吉姆去拉的时候，对吧？我不得不说，雷恩·威尔逊的演技简直绝了。他伸手去拉幕布时那种强忍痛苦的表现，我觉得他在
was brilliant in this whole episode. The way he portrayed his pain escalating, I honestly reign. Oh my God. You were so great in this episode. I thought you should have won an Emmy for playing Dwight. He was nominated three times. You and John were nominated, Steve. None of you guys won an Emmy. You all should have won Emmys. Wow. This has taken a turn. This speech. It's turned into a We deserve Emmy speech because of the pulling down of the screen. I love it. There's so many other moments.
整集里都表现得太出色了。他表现痛苦逐渐加剧的方式，说实话，雷恩。天哪。你在这集里太棒了。我觉得你应该凭扮演德怀特赢得艾美奖。他被提名了三次。你和约翰都被提名了，史蒂夫。你们谁都没拿艾美奖。你们所有人都应该拿艾美奖的。哇。这话题转折得有点大。这段演讲。演变成了一场“我们配得上艾美奖”的演讲，就因为拉下幕布这件事。我太喜欢了。还有那么多其他的时刻。
And you know, you were sitting right by me when Steve didn't win, and it was his last time nominated. And I couldn't control myself, and I said a curse word. You did. With the camera right by me. Yeah. I just thought Rain, Rain should have won an Emmy. Well, you know who agrees with you is Kelly M.
而且你知道，当史蒂夫没有获奖时，你正坐在我旁边，那是他最后一次被提名。我控制不住自己，爆了一句粗口。你确实爆了。摄像机就在我旁边。是的。我只是觉得雷恩，雷恩本该赢得一个艾美奖的。好吧，你知道谁同意你的看法吗？是来自弗吉尼亚州伍德布里奇的凯利·M。
from Woodbridge, Virginia. Kelly Ann wrote in and said, I have been waiting for so long to submit this to you ladies. I thought I would save you some time on a deep dive. I am a pediatric RN in Minnesota, and I work with kids with appendicitis nearly every shift. I have also had my own appendix removed. Oh, wow.
凯利·安写信说：我等了这么久才把这个发给你们两位女士。我想我会帮你们在深度剖析上省点时间。我是明尼苏达州的一名儿科注册护士，几乎每个班都在照顾患有阑尾炎的小朋友。我自己也切除过阑尾。哦，哇。
The most distinct symptom is when we, as medical personnel, push slightly on someone's abdomen and the most pain is actually when we release the pressure, not when we apply the pressure. We call this rebound tenderness. Appendicitis is a serious medical issue and there were a few moments that stuck out to me in this episode that shows how well Raiden Wilson performed. First is the way he walks and stands through the whole episode. As soon as he walked out of the hotel, I saw the anacids and the hunched over walk, and I had a feeling it was appendicitis.
最明显的症状是，当我们这些医务人员稍微按压某人的腹部时，最痛的其实是在我们松开压力的时候，而不是施加压力的时候。我们称之为反跳痛。阑尾炎是一个严肃的医疗问题，这一集里有几个瞬间让我印象深刻，展现了雷恩·威尔逊的演技有多好。首先是他整集走路和站立的姿态。他一走出酒店，我看到抗酸药和弓着身子的走姿，我就有种预感是阑尾炎。
When he reached for the projector screen, it was so uncomfortable but also so funny because I knew exactly how that felt because standing up straight hurt so bad when you have appendicitis. And then of course he goes on to show more symptoms and more severe pain. I have to give huge props to Rain Wilson for his spot on performance. It was just so believable.
当他伸手去够投影幕布时，看着太难受了，但也太好笑了，因为我太清楚那种感觉了，得阑尾炎时站直了实在太痛了。然后当然，他接着表现出更多的症状和更严重的剧痛。我必须给雷恩·威尔逊无可挑剔的表演点大大的赞。实在太真实了。
His gradual progression of symptoms throughout the episode is perfect and I loved every minute of it. Also, applause to Daniel Chun and the writing staff for doing their research to make this so realistic. Kellyanne, thank you for writing in. You're clearly an expert on appendicitis. And I'm so glad we did a good portrayal of this. Me too! From the writing to Reince performance, which deserved an Emmy. Yes. Dwight has finally had enough with the pain and he has called, I guess, 9-1-1.
他在整集中症状逐渐加重的过程堪称完美，我喜欢每一个瞬间。同时，也要为丹尼尔·陈和编剧团队鼓掌，他们做了深入的研究，才让这显得如此逼真。凯利·安，谢谢你来信。你显然是阑尾炎专家。我很高兴我们做出了一个好的演绎。我也是！从剧本到雷恩的表演，真的配得上一个艾美奖。是的。德怀特终于痛得受不了了，他打了，我猜是911。
I don't know who he's called. He's called someone in the medical profession, and he's saying he has symptoms that might mimic being poisoned or appendicitis. Jim's like, Dwight, I didn't poison you. Yeah. And that's when Dwight's like, get me an ambulance right away.
我不知道他打给了谁。他打给了一个医疗专业人员，他说他出现的症状可能类似于中毒或阑尾炎。吉姆说：德怀特，我没毒死你。对。然后德怀特就说：马上给我派一辆救护车。
Until he discovers that Nelly needs someone in the position of Vice President of Special Projects and then he gets off the phone. Yeah, Dwight has a phrase I am now going to adopt into my life and I'm going to say it whenever I want, especially if I'm agitated. What is it? Send it to the freaking moon, idiot. Okay, oh my goodness. That's how he cancels the ambulance.
直到他发现内莉需要有人担任特别项目副总裁的职位，然后他就挂了电话。是的，德怀特有一句话我打算融入我的生活中，以后只要我想说，尤其是当我烦躁的时候，我都要说。是什么？送它去他妈的月亮上，白痴。好吧，噢天哪。他是这么取消救护车的。
Yeah, they say, where should I send the ambulance? And he says, send it to the freaking moon, idiot. That's what I'm gonna say now. Mm-hmm, that's gonna be my new phrase. After canceling the ambulance, he's gonna saddle up to Nelly, who's having a conversation with Todd Packer about hunting. And this is when Dwight is going to explain
对，他们说，我应该把救护车派到哪去？他说，送它去他妈的月亮上，白痴。这就是我以后要说的话。嗯嗯，这将成为我的新口头禅。取消救护车后，他凑向内莉，内莉正在和托德·帕克谈论打猎的事。然后德怀特就要解释说
that he has a master hunter, but only a decent baiter. Yes, because Todd Packer is trying to mess with him. He says, did you say master baiter? And he goes, no, I'm a decent baiter. But my cousin mows, that's a master baiter. Next up for some reason, Nelly is going to suggest everyone make a human pyramid. This is very Michael Scott.
他是一个打猎大师，但只是个像模像样的诱饵手。对，因为托德·帕克在故意逗他。他说：你刚才说你是大师级的逗弄者（Masterbater）吗？他说：不，我只是个像模像样的诱饵手。但我表弟莫兹，那才是大师级的。接下来，不知为何，内莉建议大家搞一个人肉金字塔。这非常迈克尔·斯科特。
It is. But guess what? Florida Stanley is up for it, which means then Jim is up for it. Yeah. Aaron's like sure I'll do it. Steve Burgess said that our stunt coordinator, Brett Jones, had to plan this whole pyramid. And we interviewed background actors specifically to be in the pyramid. So like you knew from day one, eventually you're going to get in a human
确实。但你猜怎么着？佛罗里达斯坦利愿意参加，这意味着吉姆也愿意参加。是的，艾琳说，当然，我来。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，我们的特技协调员布雷特·琼斯不得不规划整个金字塔。我们专门面试了背景演员来组成金字塔。所以你从第一天起就知道，你最终会加入一个人肉
pyramid. They also rigged a safety line for rain for him to call up to the top. Yes, but they can take out in post, you know, and I don't know if you noticed, but Leslie is not on the bottom of that pyramid. We had a stunt person dressed as Stanley who stood in. Well, this scene was actually bigger. There was a moment where Aaron makes some small talk with a woman named Stacey who was from Tallahassee who's at this meeting. And Stacey says to Aaron, wow, you're moving here for good. Aaron says, yeah, I've never lived in a state capital before, it seems super exciting. Stacy says, well, Tallahassee's glad to have you.
金字塔。他们还为雷恩装设了一条安全绳，好让他能爬到顶端。是的，但他们可以在后期制作中剪掉，你知道的，而且我不知道你有没有注意到，莱斯利并不在那个金字塔的最底部。我们找了一个扮成斯坦利的特技替身站在那里。好吧，这个场景其实更宏大。有一个瞬间，艾琳和一个叫斯黛西的女人闲聊，斯黛西来自塔拉哈西，也来参加这个会议。斯黛西对艾琳说：哇，你要搬到这里常住吗？艾琳说：对啊，我以前从没在州首府住过，感觉超级兴奋。斯黛西说：好吧，塔拉哈西很高兴有你加入。
So what are your main priorities in a place? Cheap rent, artsy neighborhood, big yard. Erin says, I'd like to be close enough to the zoo that I can stand on my roof and throw a banana and watch a monkey catch it in its mouth. I am speechless. I am speechless. This is her hope for Tallahassee. Well, this is her criteria for living anywhere.
那么你对一个地方的主要诉求是什么？便宜的租金、有艺术气息的街区、大院子。艾琳说：我想离动物园近到我能站在屋顶上扔根香蕉，看着猴子在嘴里接住它。我无言以对。我无言以对。这就是她对塔拉哈西的期望。好吧，这就是她对在任何地方生活的标准。
I guess so. Living in a state capital. Yeah. So I was curious. Does Tallahassee have a zoo? Aaron is out of luck, but it does have 17 museums. Oh, you can go to whichmuseum.com, WHICH, whichmuseum.com. Okay. To learn more about all the museums in Tallahassee. Also, Jenna, I did find there is a Tallahassee Museum that has animal exhibits,
我想是的。住在州首府。所以很好奇。塔拉哈西有动物园吗？艾琳运气不好，那里没有，但它有17家博物馆。哦，你可以去whichmuseum.com，WHICH，whichmuseum.com。好的。去了解更多关于塔拉哈西所有博物馆的信息。另外，珍娜，我确实发现塔拉哈西有一个博物馆，里面有动物展览、
a ropes course and zip lining. It's not a zoo, but maybe that's where Aaron would have landed. Maybe so. Yeah. I'm a big museum person. I know. When I go to cities, I love a museum. One of my favorite places in the United States
绳索攀爬和滑索。它不是动物园，但也许这就是艾琳最终落脚的地方。也许吧。是的。我是个狂热的博物馆爱好者。我知道。每到一个城市，我都超爱逛博物馆。我在美国最喜欢的地方之一
is Santa Fe, New Mexico. They have so much history stuff. We were just there. We went to Bandle Air National Monument. I highly recommend a trip to Santa Fe, New Mexico. It's a hidden gem of the United States. And if I ever go to Florida, I'm going to check out these museums. I mean, I feel like Tallahassee has a lot of cool things to see.
是新墨西哥州的圣达菲。那里有太多的历史文化内容。我们刚去过。我们去了班德利尔国家纪念碑。我强烈推荐去新墨西哥州圣达菲旅游。它是美国的一颗隐藏的宝石。如果我以后去佛罗里达，我一定要去看看这些博物馆。我是说，我觉得塔拉哈西有很多很酷的景点。
I think Aaron's going to do well there. She can give up the weird monkey banana dream. Yeah, because that's she's not going to find that. She's not going to get that. Well, back to the episode, this human pyramid is not going to go well for Dwight. He's going to end up on a stretcher. It's an emergency. He needs his appendix out.
我觉得艾琳在那儿会过得不错。她可以放弃那个奇怪的猴子香蕉梦了。对，因为她找不到那样的。她实现不了那个。好吧，回到剧集，这个人肉金字塔对德怀特来说可不太妙。他最终会被送上担架。这是个紧急情况。他得切除阑尾。
Back at Dundermiff once, Grant and Anti is really leveling up his reception game. He's made many pizzas. Mm-hmm. They're very popular. And he's faxing up a storm. He's shredding and faxing at the same time. Yeah, he says, Daryl, awesome news. Your fax went through and Darryl says, ah, f*** yeah. I had to know.
回到邓德米夫林，安迪的前台业务水平真的在飞速提升。他做了很多比萨。嗯嗯。它们非常受欢迎。而且他一直在疯狂发传真。他同时在碎纸和发传真。是的，他说：达里尔，好消息。你的传真发过去了，达里尔说：啊，操，太棒了。我必须知道。
I had to know if this was scripted and it was verbatim. Wow. This also brings me to the question, why is getting a fax through such a big deal? Has Aaron not been able to get faxes through? I feel like we have learned that she has trouble with the fax machine. That is a thing. It is. And did you catch the pin display at Andy's reception area?
我必须知道这台词是不是剧本写的，结果真是一个字不差。哇。这也让我产生了一个疑问，为什么传真发过去是一件这么大不了的事？难道艾琳以前一直发不出传真吗？我觉得我们了解到她用传真机确实有困难。这是个老问题了。确实。而且你注意到安迪前台区域的图钉展示了吗？
Yeah. A tier of pins, all layered, a row of green pins, blue, yellow, and one red one at the top. There was an extended scene. It's in the deleted scenes of Andy making this. Really? Yes. We watch him make the pen tower. Yes. Wow. Back in Tallahassee, Dwight has called Aaron, I guess, from the hospital post-surgery, and he wants to know what's going on. And she says, we're giving presentations. Let me tell you, the last person you want to give you information about anything is Aaron. I mean, she doesn't do a bad job here.
看到了。一排排的图钉，错落有致，一排绿色的图钉、蓝色的、黄色的，顶上还有一个红色的。这里有一个加长片段。安迪制作这个过程的片段在被删减片段里。真的吗？是的。我们看着他制作图钉塔。是的。哇。回到塔拉哈西，德怀特手术后大概从医院给艾琳打了电话，他想知道情况怎么样。她说：我们正在做演示。跟你说吧，你最不想让谁来给你提供任何信息，那个人就是艾琳。我是说，她在这里表现得还不赖。
She tells him what he needs to know, I guess. No, but then she goes, let me see what also you miss. Ryan switched his name tag to his pants. So now it's like, if you wear yours on your shirt, you're a total dip. But if you switch, you're a copycat. But I think I figured out a solution. What else? My shoes are gone. And he's just like, click. Where do you wear your name tag when you put a name tag on? Do you put it on your chest? Yeah. Every time. Yeah. Where do you put yours? If it says my name, I put it on my chest, but if it's like some weird like pass in order to get into a building
她把该告诉他的都告诉他了，我猜。没有，但接着她说：让我看看你还错过了什么。瑞安把他的名牌别到了裤子上。所以现在的情况是，如果你把名牌别在衬衫上，你就是个绝对的笨蛋。但如果你换到裤子上，你就是个模仿精。不过我想我找到了一个解决办法。还有什么？我的鞋子不见了。然后他就直接挂了电话。你把名牌戴在什么地方？你会把它别在胸口吗？对。每一次。是的。你把你的别在哪？如果是写着我的名字，我就别在胸口，但如果是什么奇怪的通行证，为了进一栋大楼
or like go to a meeting or something. I put it down low. I put it maybe on my hip or on the lower part of my shirt. What is your thinking there? I mean, I think I'm annoyed that I have to wear it and I don't want it. You sure? You sure protest?
或者去开会什么的。我会别得比较低。我可能会把它别在臀部或者衬衫靠下的地方。你这么做是怎么想的？我是说，我觉得我很讨厌必须戴着它，我不想把它……真的吗？你这是在抗议？
I don't know, I don't want it up. If I'm wearing it because I'm part of a group setting and it's like, hello, my name is, You don't want it. You want it. You want it. You want it. You want it. I don't know. I don't want it up. If I'm wearing it because I'm part of a group setting and it's like, hello, my name is, I'll put it up high so you can read it. But if it's just a pass, I don't know. It's funny because I go to physical therapy a couple of times a week and in order to go
不知道，我不想把它别得高高的。如果我戴着它是因为我是集体活动的一部分，上面写着“你好，我的名字是……”，你不想戴。你很想戴。你很想戴。你很想戴。你很想戴。不知道。我不想把它别得高高的。如果我戴着它是因为我是集体活动的一部分，上面写着“你好，我的名字是……”，我会把它别得高高的，这样你能看清。但如果它只是个出入证，我不知道。说来搞笑，我一周去几次物理治疗，为了去
to physical therapy, I have to stop at the visitor's desk at the hospital and I say, I'm here for physical therapy. And then they give me a little sticker that is like my pass. Yeah. I don't put it up high, I put it down low. This is such a wild piece of information to learn about you. And like when I go to, for example, the Natural History Museum in New York,
做物理治疗，我必须在医院的访客前台停下来，我说：我是来做物理治疗的。然后他们会给我一个小贴纸作为我的出入证。是的。我不会把它别得高高在上，我会别得低低的。了解到你身上有这么疯狂的一个小秘密，真是太神奇了。比如当我去参观，比如说纽约的自然历史博物馆时，
they give you a little bit of down low. Oh, I put it down low. I, what is that? I don't know, it's a weird act of rebellion against the system. Is it? You're not going to tell me I'm allowed to come in here. I'll show you. Is that what it is?
他们也会给你一个小贴纸……低低的。哦，我把它别得低低的。我，那是什么？不知道，这是对体制的一种奇怪的反叛行为。是吗？你休想命令我能进到这儿来。我让你瞧瞧。是这么回事吗？
I don't know. Why won't I display it up high? It's hilarious. I'm like, you're messing up my outfit. An outfit that I've spent no time putting together. It's not like I'm a fashionista or something. Oh, gosh. But I'm like, I don't want you to like ruin my look with this sticker.
我不知道。我为什么不把它别在显眼的高处呢？太爆笑了。我就觉得：你在毁我的造型。一个我根本没花时间搭配的造型。我又不是什么时尚达人。哦，天哪。但我就觉得：我才不想让你用这个小贴纸毁了我的行头呢。
I don't know. I thought it wasn't when this whole thing came up. I was like, oh my gosh, I... You're Ryan. Sometimes? Sometimes. Well Dwight is gonna find out that Packer is giving a presentation and that's it. He leaves the hospital. And he walks into the conference room with his IV drip and this is where I start to unravel. I really hate it in movies when people leave the hospital to earn. And I really bothers me when they drag their IV drip with them. I don't like it. I know. Rain is so good in the scene. He's in so much pain and he's doing such a shitty job at giving this presentation. so much pain and he's doing such a shitty job at giving this presentation. He's getting everything wrong and he has Aaron whispering in the details like the three pillars of retail. Aaron says convenience. Dwight goes ingredients. Aaron says service. Dwight says burgers. Aaron says
不知道。当整件事发生的时候我想的是：天哪，我……你就是瑞安。有时候吧？有时候。好吧，德怀特发现帕克正在做演示，就这一下。他离开了医院。他挂着点滴走进了会议室，正是在这里我开始情绪失控。我真的很讨厌电影里人们为了搞业绩而离开医院的桥段。而且他们拖着静脉滴注架一起走，这真的让我很抓狂。我不喜欢这样。我知道。雷恩在这个场景里太棒了。他痛得要死，而且做这个演示简直烂透了。痛得要死，做这个演示简直烂透了。他把所有东西都搞错了，还得让艾琳在旁边耳语提示细节，比如零售业的三大支柱。艾琳说：便利性。德怀特说：成分。艾琳说：服务。德怀特说：汉堡。艾琳说
building loyalty. He goes killing royalty. And then it spirals from there. Well, one of the things that happens in that speech is that the team had a slide where they were going to talk about consumer habits. But of course, he doesn't know what they plan to say. So he says something about how women shop more when they're on their periods because they're depressed that they didn't procreate. I wanted to know, Is there any correlation? Remember how we're always like sometimes Dwight is right?
培养忠诚度。他说：消灭皇室。然后情况就彻底失控了。好吧，那场演讲中发生的事情之一，是团队有一张幻灯片，准备谈论消费者的习惯。但当然，他根本不知道他们打算说啥。所以他开始瞎扯说女性在经期因为没有生育而感到沮丧，所以购物会更疯狂。我想知道，这之间有什么关联吗？还记得我们总是说，有时德怀特其实是对的吗？
Yeah, I mean, he's like sometimes he says some crazy thing and then he ends up right. You're absolutely right. He's done it many times. He had that whole thing about Fair Mones. So what do you think? Is Dwight right about women spending more or shopping more during their periods? Is this just a purely sexist rant or is there any science behind it? I don't feel like shopping.
对啊，我是说，他经常说一些疯狂的话，然后最后证明他是对的。你绝对没说错。他已经做好几次了。他以前关于荷尔蒙的那整套理论也是。所以你怎么看？德怀特关于女性在经期花更多钱或买更多东西的说法是对的吗？这纯粹是一场性别歧视的胡言乱语，还是背后真有什么科学依据？我可不想购物。
I don't know. I'm like, I don't feel like I don't want to leave the house. Exactly. I want to be on the couch with like a hot pad on my stomach. I want to take it easy. Well, Glamour Magazine published an article, Glamour Magazine, again, on the subject of shopping and women's menstrual cycles. They cited a study that claimed women do exhibit less control over their spending habits, but not during their period, during the 10 days leading up to their period known as the luteal phase. This was what happens in the luteal phase.
不知道。我当时就想：我一点都不想出门。没错。我只想躺在沙发上，肚子上贴个热敷垫。我想好好休息。好吧，《魅力》杂志发表了一篇文章，《魅力》杂志，又是它，关于购物和女性月经周期的主题。他们引用了一项研究，声称女性确实表现出对消费习惯的控制力下降，但不是在经期，而是在经期前被称为黄体期的那10天里。黄体期会发生这种事。
Well, the luteal phase happens in the second part of your menstrual cycle. It starts around day 15, and then it ends when you get your period. The luteal phase is what is preparing your uterus for pregnancy by thickening your utel lining. That's what I was going to say. Is this sort of like when you're like, let's make a baby? Yes, it is the phase that happens right after ovulation. So right after your ovary releases the egg, you go into the l loodle phase. That's when you want to spend money. You want to prepare. Well, it's like this natural instinct. You're like, I've released an egg, anything can happen.
好吧，黄体期发生在月经周期的后半段。它从第15天左右开始，到你来月经时结束。黄体期是通过增厚子宫内膜来为怀孕做准备的阶段。我正要这么说。这有点像是当你心想：我们生个孩子吧？是的，它就发生在排卵后不久。所以就在卵巢释放卵子之后，你就会进入黄体期。那正是你想花钱的时候。你想做好准备。好吧，这就像是一种本能。你会想：我已经排卵了，什么都有可能发生。
I better buy stuff and get ready. Well, this recently published study, it examined 443 women. It was conducted by a woman, Professor Karen Pine in the UK, and they found that women in the little phase were two-thirds more likely to do impulse buying during this phase, and that 57% said that they often overspent. And I guess Professor Karen Pine decided that the spending behavior tends to be a reaction to the intense emotions that flood in during this phase of our menstrual cycles. Karen also said, during this time, women can feel very stressed or depressed and are more likely to go shopping to cheer themselves up or to regulate their emotions,
我最好买点东西做好准备。好吧，最近发表的这项研究调查了443名女性。它是由英国的一位女性卡伦·派恩教授进行的，他们发现处于黄体期的女性在此期间冲动购物的可能性要高出三分之二，而且57%的人表示她们经常过度消费。我猜卡伦·派恩教授得出结论，这种消费行为往往是对我们月经周期这个阶段涌现出的强烈情绪的一种反应。卡伦还说，在这段时间里，女性会感到非常压力山大或沮丧，因而更有可能通过购物来让自己开心起来或调节情绪，
because it is a more socially sanctioned way to deal with emotional overload compared to drinking or drugs. This was Karen's study. So I guess there could be some spending habits linked to the menstrual cycle. Yeah. In which case, Dwight is a little bit right, but Dwight is actually wrong. Dwight says that you overspend while having your period. Right. No, we're done spending. We're done. We're done. We're done. But he always has something in this sort of topic about women and their bodies. Like it's like Dwight is very attuned some way to like what makes a woman function in his own way. Yes, and I don't know how I feel about this study.
因为与喝酒或吸毒相比，这是一种更能被社会接受的应对情绪过载的方式。这就是卡伦的研究。所以我想，确实会有一些与月经周期相关的消费习惯。在这种情况下，德怀特稍微有点对，但德怀特其实又说错了。德怀特说的是你在来月经的时候过度消费。不对。不，我们早就不买东西了。我们花完了。我们结束了。但他在关于女性及其身体这个话题上总能说出点什么。就好像德怀特以他自己的方式对女性的生理机能有一种奇特的敏感。是的，我不知道该怎么看待这项研究。
I have to say like part of me is like, do we need more of these stereotypes about women and their emotions and the way they deal with them during their periods. Or is it comforting because you're maybe going through these ups and downs and you're like, oh good, I'm not the only person experiencing these intense highs and lows. I think it's a combo platter. It's a combo platter.
我得说，一部分的我在想：我们还需要更多关于女性及其情绪以及她们在经期如何应对这些刻板印象吗？还是说这其实挺让人安心的，因为你可能正在经历这些情绪的大起大落，然后你会想：哦太好了，我不是唯一一个经历这种强烈情绪高潮和低谷的人。我觉得这是一个大拼盘。这是一个大拼盘。
Yeah. Well Dwight ultimately wins Nelly over with his presentation. Mm-hmm. And Jim points out he's bleeding through his shirt. And then I can't even talk about it. Nelly has to see Dwight's wound. And then Todd Packer tries to poke it. Ah! That was so gross.
嗯。好吧，德怀特最终用他的演示赢得了内莉的好感。嗯嗯。然后吉姆指出他的衬衫都在渗血。接着我简直没法聊这个了。内莉必须看看德怀特的伤口。然后托德·帕克试图去戳它。啊！太恶心了。
And then Dwight spots his finger away, but just the suggestion that his wound was gonna be poked. I didn't even think about the pain of having an open wound poked. All I could think about was. I guess it's making me feel okay, okay, okay. I have to say this, I have to say this. All I could think about in the moment was how dirty Todd Packers hands are. I can think about, I don't want Todd Packers nasty finger. Sweetie.
然后德怀特把他的手拍开，但仅仅是那种伤口要被戳一下的暗示。我甚至都没去想戳开一个伤口会有多痛。我满脑子想的都是……我觉得这让我感觉……好吧，好吧，好吧。我必须得说这个，我必须得说这个。我当时满脑子想的都是托德·帕克的手有多脏。我能想到的就是，我才不要托德·帕克那只恶心的脏手。亲爱的。
I can't. I can't. Jenna has doubled over. Oh God. I don't think it's making me feel like I just ran for me. I'm switching. I'm switching the subject. I'm switching the subject. I'm switching the subject.
我受不了了。我受不了了。珍娜已经笑弯了腰。天哪。我觉得这没让我觉得我刚跑完步。我要换话题了。我要换话题了。我要换话题了。我要换话题了。
Ready? This is a perfect timing for my last telehathy tidbit. Did you know that telehassy has a nickname? What is it? It is Trayla-hassy. What? That's right, because telehassy has 700 miles of trails, winding through its rolling hills, towering pines,
准备好了吗？这正是我最后一个关于塔拉哈西的趣闻的完美时机。你知道塔拉哈西有个绰号吗？是什么？是“小径哈西”（Trail-a-hassee）。什么？没错，因为塔拉哈西有700英里长的小径，蜿蜒穿过起伏的丘陵、高耸的松树、
and crystal clear rivers and springs, it is a nature lovers paradise for bird watching. You can hike, you can kayak, you can go fishing, but there's lots of hiking, so it's got a nickname, Tallahassee. I have to say something. Yeah, Tallahassee sounds awesome. I know.
以及清澈见底的河流和泉水，它是观鸟爱好者的天堂。你可以远足、划皮划艇、钓鱼，这里有大量的远足路线，所以它有个绰号叫塔拉哈西。我必须说点什么。好吧，塔拉哈西听起来太棒了。我知道。
I mean, the museums, the hiking, it's probably good weather. I did not look up the weather. Well, there was the person who wrote in the other week about how like it has nice weather. Oh yeah, should we go there? I mean, I'm really interested after all of these facts you've told me today. Listen, you had me at Birdwatching. Okay, I want to go to Tal Hassey.
我是说，那些博物馆、远足，天气可能也不错。我没查过天气。好吧，上周确实有人写信说那里天气很好。哦，对，我们应该去那儿吗？我是说，听了你今天讲的这些事实，我真的很感兴趣。听着，你用观鸟成功吸引了我。好吧，我想去塔拉哈西。
Did I pivot enough for you? Yeah, I'm coming, I'm getting back. Are you coming out of it? Yeah, okay. Let's go back to Dundra Mifflin. Let's do fan catch from Brandon R and Illinois. I'm sure everyone will point this out, but it's the mail cart.
我这个话题转得够圆滑了吧？对，我来了，我正绕回来呢。你从阴影里走出来了吗？是的，好吧。我们回邓德米夫林吧。我们来看看来自伊利诺伊州的布兰登·R的粉丝趣闻。我确信每个人都会指出这一点，那就是那个邮件推车。
Oh, Andy is pushing around the mail cart. The thing that we said never moved. Never moves. But when he's passing out the mail, lady, can I ask this question, why are Oscars taxes coming to his workplace? I don't know. What is that?
哦，安迪在推着邮件推车。就是我们说过从不移动的东西。从不移动。但当他在分发邮件时，女士，我可以问个问题吗，为什么奥斯卡的税务文件会寄到他的工作地点？不知道。那是什么鬼？
He doesn't want to get his taxes at home. It's weird. That is a weird detail that was missed on me. Next up is a scene that I found odd. And I have a question for you about it. Okay. Pam and Darrell approach Andy at reception. And they're like trying to talk Andy out of
他不想把税务文件寄到家里。这很奇怪。这是一个我漏掉的奇怪细节。接下来是一个我觉得很古怪的场景。我有个问题想问你。好的。帕姆和达里尔在前台找到了安迪。他们试图劝说安迪
being the receptionist. And it didn't really make sense to me because he's doing a really, really good job. And Pam didn't want to do the job anyway. So I actually went to the script and I saw that there was originally the storyline where Andy is not doing a good job. He's kind of ignoring his job as manager because he gets so distracted by reception and people are really frustrated, particularly Kelly. And that's why Pam and Darryl have this scene where they're like, Andy, it's time to give up reception.
不要再当接待员了。这让我觉得有点说不通，因为他干得真的，真的很好。而且帕姆本来就不想干这份工作。所以我特意去看了剧本，发现原本有一个剧情线是安迪其实干得并不好。他因为太沉迷于前台的工作而有点忽视了经理的职责，大家对此非常沮丧，尤其是凯利。这就是为什么帕姆和达里尔会有这个场景，他们对安迪说：安迪，是时候放弃前台的工作了。
Yeah. Is that in deleted scenes at all? Did we shoot it? A little bit. Basically, there's a storyline with Kelly and Creed where Kelly said she was promised a raise. And Andy goes, I never promised you a raise. And she said, the manager before you did and Creed goes, that's right. I promised her a raise. Yeah, that's right. He also promised himself a raise. That's right.
是的。那段在被删减片段里吗？我们拍过吗？拍了一点。基本上，有一条关于凯利和克里德的剧情线，凯利说她被承诺过要加薪。然后安迪说：我从来没答应过给你加薪。她说：你之前的经理答应过，克里德接着说：没错。我答应过给她加薪。是的，没错。他还答应给自己加薪呢。没错。
And Andy's like, we don't have any money for raises guys. We don't have any money. And then Phyllis goes, does that mean I'm not getting my raise? And he's like, Phyllis, I told you not to say anything about that. So he had given fill us a raise, but isn't going to honor Creed's raises. Yeah. And Kelly is pissed off the whole entire episode,
然后安迪说：我们根本没有钱给大家加薪，伙计们。我们一分钱也没有。接着菲利斯说：那是不是意味着我没有加薪了？然后安迪说：菲利斯，我告诉过你不要提这件事的。所以他其实给菲利斯加过薪，但却不打算兑现对克里德的加薪承诺。是的。而且凯利整集都气急败坏，
demanding that Andy answer for this the whole episode. And he's kind of hiding out at reception. Yeah, so he doesn't have to deal with it. That's right. There's scenes where Kelly and Creed go up to talk to him and he's like, oh, sorry, I got to take this call. Oh, I got to do this facts. And he just keeps punting this conversation with Kelly and Creed. Okay. Got it. So Andy, I guess does reflect and think, okay, maybe I shouldn't be the receptionist, but I do want to point out that there's a month of no one answering phones now. I guess so.
整集都在要求安迪对此给个说法。而他有点躲在前台后面。是的，这样他就不用去处理这事了。没错。有些场景是凯利和克里德走过去找他，然后他说：哦，抱歉，我得接个电话。哦，我得去发个传真。他就一直把和凯利、克里德的谈话往后推。好吧。明白了。所以安迪，我想他确实反思并认为：好吧，也许我不该当这个接待员。不过我要指出的是，现在已经有一个月没人接电话了。我想是的。
What's going to happen next week? I'm so curious. He's going to answer the phone. I don't know. He does take a call from a client who misses Aaron, and he realizes he misses her too. Mm-hmm. I'm sorry, I like him with Jessica. I know you do.
下周会发生什么？我太好奇了。他会去接电话的。我不知道。他确实接到了一个想念艾琳的客户的电话，然后他意识到他也想念艾琳了。嗯嗯。抱歉，我其实挺喜欢他和杰西卡的。我知道你喜欢。
I... Listen, I'm rooting for Jessica as well. Back in Tallahassee, Dwight has a talking head. He said he had two goals today, to make himself a clear candidate for Vice President, which he believes he achieved, and to find a memorable souvenir for Philip, which he achieved thanks to his appendix.
我……听着，我也支持杰西卡。回到塔拉哈西，德怀特有一个面对镜头的独白。他说他今天有两个目标，一是把自己塑造成副总裁的明确人选，他认为自己做到了；二是为菲利普找到一个值得纪念的纪念品，多亏了他的阑尾，他也做到了。
Yes, we had a fan question from Olivia O. in Ireland, who said, I was wondering, when Dwight holds up his appendix as a souvenir to give Philip what was used as the fake appendix, it looks so realistically gross and it made me think of who had to put that together. You know Phil Shea did. He did. And I actually was very curious. What was in the bag? Like what happens when Phil Sheh reads a script and he realizes that he has to come up with an appendix in a baggy. So lady, I reached out and asked him poor Phil Sheh. These are the things we text him about. He said that he rented this fake appendix from a makeup and body parts special effects company called Matthew Mungle. Hold up. Yep. You can rent a fake appendix.
是的，我们收到了来自爱尔兰的奥利维亚·O的粉丝提问，她说：我想知道，当德怀特举起他的阑尾作为送给菲利普的纪念品时，那个用作道具的假阑尾看起来太逼真恶心了，这让我想到究竟是谁把这东西做出来的。你知道是菲尔·谢伊做的。他确实做了。而且我其实很好奇。袋子里装的是什么？当菲尔·谢伊读到剧本并意识到他得弄出一个带血袋的阑尾时，会发生什么？所以女士，我联系并问了他，可怜的菲尔·谢伊。这就是我们发短信找他帮忙的事。他说他从一家名为马修·芒格的化妆和身体部位特效公司租了这个假阑尾。等等。没错。你居然能租到假阑尾。
You can rent all kinds of fake body parts from Matthew Mungle. Oh my lord. Yeah. But it gets better. Phil said they actually had a few appendix to choose from. So he presented them probably on a silver tray to our writer Danny and director Matt Sone,
你可以从马修·芒格那里租到各种各样的假身体部位。哦，天哪。是的。但更棒的是。菲尔说他们实际上有几个盲肠可供选择。所以他可能把它们放在一个银盘子里端给我们的编剧丹妮和导演马特·索恩，
and they picked the one they liked. Oh my gosh. Phil said that when he reads a script, he breaks it down into categories. The categories are rentals, purchases, and design. He said also he looks for any promo opportunities. Is there any way to get a company to give the money if the product product? Yeah.
然后他们挑了一个自己喜欢的。哦，天哪。菲尔说，当他读剧本时，他会把它分成不同的类别。这些类别是租赁、采购和设计。他还说他会寻找任何宣传的机会。有没有什么办法能让公司在产品出色的情况下出资？是的。
Also, he said if something does need to be designed, he has subcategories. Is it something they can make in-house or something they have to source elsewhere? And he only ever has a week to get it all done. That's just fascinating to me that he pulls that off every week. It's just amazing. Amazing. So thank you Phil for giving me the lowdown on how you got to fake appendix. This episode is going to end with a very special guest. Nelly brings in Wally Amos of famous Amos cookies. As he starts his speech, all anyone can think about is are there cookies?
此外，他说如果真的需要设计什么，他还有子类别。这是他们可以自己内部制作的，还是必须从别处采购的？而且他通常只有一周时间把所有这些都搞定。这对我来说太不可思议了，他每周都能完成。这简直太惊人了。太惊人了。所以谢谢菲尔向我透露了你是如何找到假盲肠的内幕。这一集将以一位非常特殊的嘉宾结束。内莉请来了著名菲力曲奇的创始人沃利·阿莫斯。当他开始演讲时，每个人脑子里想的都是：有曲奇吗？
Can I eat them now? Can I open the cookies? They do not want his motivational speech. No. They just want the cookies. Everyone, this was the real Wally Amos of famous Amos cookies. He was the first and only person ever scripted for this bit at the end of the episode. He is originally from Florida.
我现在能吃吗？我可以打开曲奇吗？他们根本不想听他的励志演讲。不。他们只想吃曲奇。各位，这就是著名菲力曲奇的真正的沃利·阿莫斯。他是本集结尾这段情节中唯一一个也是第一个被安排写进剧本的人。他原本来自佛罗里达州。
Steve Burgess says that Alice and Jones contacted his reps and he was interested. So we got to make it happen. It is a little complicated, though, because he is no longer associated with famous Amos cookies, the cookie that he invented. His story is fascinating. It has a lot of ups and downs. I'm going to tell it to you. He no longer has famous Amos cookies and he's famous Amos.
史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，艾莉森·琼斯联系了他的经纪人，而且他很感兴趣。所以我们得促成这件事。不过这有点复杂，因为他不再与著名菲力曲奇——他自己发明的曲奇——有任何关联了。他的故事很迷人。有起有伏。我要讲给你听。他不再拥有著名菲力曲奇了，而他就是著名的阿莫斯。
Okay. Yes. What happened? So first of all, he was born in Florida. He eventually moved to Los Angeles and got a job in the mail room at the William Morris Talent Agency. He worked his way up from the mail room
好吧。是的。发生了什么？首先，他出生在佛罗里达州。他后来搬到了洛杉矶，并在威廉·莫里斯经纪公司的收发室找到了一份工作。他从收发室一步步做起，
to become the first black talent agent in the industry. He was the head of the rock and roll department. He signed Simon and Garfunkel. He worked with people like Diana Ross, Sam Cook, and Dion Warwick. Wow. But while he was working there, he was just getting sort of disillusioned with show business. And so, to relieve stress, he started baking in his free time.
成为了行业内的第一位黑人经纪人。他是摇滚乐部门的负责人。他签下了西蒙和加芬克尔。他曾与戴安娜·罗斯、萨姆·库克和迪恩·沃里克等名人合作。哇。但当他在那里工作时，他开始对演艺界产生了一种幻灭感。因此，为了缓解压力，他开始在空闲时间烘焙。
And he would make his aunts cookie recipes and bring them to meetings. And people loved them. Like people started saying, well, you bring cookies to the meeting. So in 1975, he opened a cookie store on Sunset Boulevard, and he only sold three kinds of cookies. Chocolate chip, peanut butter, chocolate chip with pecan, and butter scotch chip with pecan. They were a zero-preservative cookie.
他会制作他姑妈的曲奇秘方，并带到会议上。人们非常喜欢它们。就像人们开始说，嗯，你把曲奇带到会议上吧。所以在1975年，他在日落大道开了一家曲奇店，他只卖三种曲奇。巧克力豆味、花生酱味、山核桃巧克力豆味以及山核桃奶油糖果豆味。它们是不含防腐剂的曲奇。
Basically, the first craft cookie, the first like gourmet cookie, right, shop. It was a huge hit. He quit being a talent agent by 1982. He was making like $12 million in revenue, and he became famous as famous Amos cookies. Wow. He started appearing on television shows as himself,
基本上是第一款手工曲奇，第一款类似精致曲奇的店铺，对吧？它非常成功。到1982年，他不再做经纪人了。他的营业额达到了约1200万美元，并作为“著名阿莫斯”（Famous Amos）曲奇而闻名。哇。他开始以本人的身份出现在电视节目中，
but eventually, I guess there started to be some trouble financially with the company, and he sold it, and then it was resold and resold, and eventually, the owners of the company started adding shelf stable ingredients to it, and they started mass producing them and putting them in grocery stores, and they were a huge success.
但最终，我猜公司开始出现一些财务问题，他把它卖掉了，然后它被转卖了一次又一次，最终，公司的所有者开始在其中添加保质期稳定的成分，他们开始大规模生产并将它们放入杂货店，它们取得了巨大的成功。
But Amos was not caching in on any of this because when he sold the cookie, he sold his name. He sold everything. He sold all the rights to it. Oh, so he tried to launch a new hazelnut cookie as Wally Amos presents. And that company that owned famous Amos sued him because he had put the name Wally Amos on his new cookies and they won. He was told he could never put his name on another cookie again. That's horrible. Horrible. So he launched another cookie called Uncle No Name.
但阿莫斯并没有从中赚到钱，因为当他卖掉曲奇时，他连同自己的名字一起卖了。他把一切都卖了。他卖掉了所有的权利。哦，所以他尝试以“沃利·阿莫斯呈献”的名义推出一款新的榛子曲奇。而拥有著名菲力曲奇的那家公司起诉了他，因为他在新曲奇上用了“沃利·阿莫斯”这个名字，结果他们打赢了。他被告知此后永远不能再把自己的名字印在任何曲奇上。太可怕了。太可怕了。于是他推出了另一款名为“无名叔叔”（Uncle No Name）的曲奇。
Like no name. No Name. Is it pronounced No Name? Well, it's spelled NO and AME and the E has a little like, you know, thing on it. Okay. Like the French do. Okay. So I assume it's called No Name. Okay. It's called no name. Well, I didn't know the spelling. Okay. So now we have uncle no name. Cookies. Those did not work out. Finally, in 1999, he signed on to be a spokesperson for the famous Amos cookie. The cookie he invented. The cookie he invented, but like he was just like, imagine if you invented Verizon wireless, but all you could do was be the spokesperson for Verizon. You were just like the guy on the commercial. So still, he was getting no revenue.
就像无名。无名。是发音为“No Name”吗？嗯，它是拼作NO和AME，而且那个E上面有一个小小的，你知道的，符号。好吧。就像法式拼写那样。好吧。所以我猜它叫无名。好吧。它叫无名。嗯，我不知道拼写。好吧。所以现在我们有了无名叔叔曲奇。那些没能成功。最后，在1999年，他签约成为著名菲力曲奇的代言人。他发明的曲奇。他发明的曲奇，但他就像是——想象一下你发明了威瑞森无线，但你唯一能做的事就是当威瑞森的代言人。你只是广告里的那个人。所以，他依然没有获得收益。
He was just like, you know, the commercial guy. Anyway, eventually he moved to Hawaii. He started a company selling muffins, he wrote multiple books about his experiences, and he is a motivational speaker, and his signature shirt and hat are on display at the Smithsonian National Museum of History, and we flew him in from Hawaii to do this episode.
他只是，你知道的，那个广告里的人。总之，最后他搬到了夏威夷。他创办了一家销售松饼的公司，他写了多本关于自己经历的书，他是一位励志演讲家，他标志性的衬衫和帽子在史密森尼国家历史博物馆展出，我们把他从夏威夷请来录制这一集。
And famous aimists agreed to let us feature the cookies on the show. But only if we bought real Famous Amos cookies we couldn't have any props. Wow. Isn't that like, it's fascinating. I hate that he lost the rights to his own name. His own name. Yes.
而著名菲力曲奇同意让我们在节目中展示这些曲奇。但前提是我们必须购买真正的著名菲力曲奇，我们不能使用任何道具。哇。这难道不，这太迷人了。我讨厌他失去了自己名字的版权。他自己的名字。是的。
And I watched a bunch of videos of him as a motivational speaker because we got this fan question from Roz F. in Washington DC who said I've always felt bad that Wally Amos didn't get to deliver a motivational speech because I've heard him speak and he's quite inspirational and Ross is correct. So yeah, what a story. What a story. I'm so glad to have learned all of that. Yeah, I know. I want to say something, but I don't want to get sued by famous Amos people, but you want to say. But there's only one famous Amos, and that's Wally Amos. I think you can say that. Well, that was Tallahassee. Everybody, I had a lot of fun revisiting this episode. Yes, a big thank you to Steve Burgess and Phil Shea, who helped me fill in some
我看了很多他作为励志演讲者的视频，因为我们收到了来自华盛顿特区的罗兹·F的粉丝提问，他说我一直觉得很遗憾，沃利·阿莫斯没能发表一场励志演讲，因为我听过他演讲，他相当具有启发性，罗兹说得对。所以，是的，真是个故事。真是个故事。我很高兴能了解到这一切。是的，我知道。我想说点什么，但我不想被著名菲力曲奇的人起诉，但你想说什么。不过，只有一个著名菲力，那就是沃利·阿莫斯。我想你可以这么说。好吧，那是塔拉哈西。各位，重温这一集我过得很开心。是的，非常感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯和菲尔·谢伊，他们帮我填补了这一集的一些
blanks for this episode. We won't be here next week because we'll be in Toronto, but when we come back, we have a lot to talk about. It's after hours. Mm-hmm, and a lot happens and after hours. That sure does. We really get into it. Have a great week everyone. See you later!
空白。我们下周不会在这里，因为我们要去多伦多，但当我们回来时，有很多事情要谈。那是下班后。嗯哼，下班后发生了很多事。确实如此。我们真的深入探讨了。大家度过愉快的一周。回头见！
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keifer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rover Tree by Creed Bratton. you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、詹妮弗和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。我们的主题曲是里德·勃拉特恩的《Rover Tree》。谢谢你。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。